let's talk about
uh cpac trump's speech okay what he's
and i'm not talking about cruz
or any of the other guy matt gates i'm
specifically
focusing on trump's speech what was your
biggest takeaway from what he said at
the cpac
curious because me to start this the
first time he came out so why don't you
take the lead
so uh obviously he did his greatest hits
you know joe biden's the worst president
we've ever seen in the first month and
yeah the radical left and by the way the
country has seems to be doing okay
for the last month or two since biden's
like
the whole like the country's gonna fall
apart and the communists are taking over
i've
pretty much enjoyed life for the last 30
60 days
sort of stress-free stress it was a
little insurrection at the capitol but
who's you know paying attention to that
but the thing that stuck out to me the
most wasn't so much the greatest hits
wasn't the talking about
how horrible sleepy joe is it's the
specific singling out of
any republican who dared
to cross him like if you didn't pray to
the golden calf of donald trump
he came after you uh liz cheney um
the the guy in uh he's very outspoken
adam
someone help me out here adam uh he's in
chicago
congressman adam kenna kenowitz i forget
his last name
kai you got a name for me adam something
chicago congressman uh illinois
congressman
awesome guy um all those guys he's
specifically saying if you voted
not lock and step with trump and you
voted to impeach him or did anything he
is coming
after you yeah adam kinzinger sorry i
knew it was adam k um
who doesn't do that though i'm curious
like you tell me what politician or
president doesn't come after the person
but it doesn't
call them out by name and singles them
out and
you know so this guy at least is being
truthful about who
you so so the mistake on his is he
publicly shares his strength i don't i
don't i don't
but i just want you to know in the world
and this is not an out i'll take shots
at the areas that he doesn't but
you name me one politician that's not
going to remember that you you tell me
obama wouldn't want to come back after
trump to make sure he didn't get
reelected
you you mean to tell me a bush didn't go
come back after you mean to tell me none
of that none of those guys i see your
point i think you're right
clearly that's in their mind but what we
are witnessing
is the oral vindictiveness of this man
like i'm not saying behind closed doors
buddy that's probably the people
well i agree the james baker book the
james baker book i don't know if you
know who james baker is yeah
long-time republican
he's the genius behind the genius he was
logical right he was not the emotional
guy he was a logical guy
let me tell you everything when you go
into politics
if you don't know how to play dirty you
ever watch these guys you're like
you know what a sweet man mike huckabee
is like you know it's a sweet man you
know
look his daughter could anyone ever said
that yeah he's a sweet
how come how come he can how come he
didn't run for how come he couldn't win
it
you look at some of these other ben
carson what a sweetheart of a man
okay how come he didn't win george w
bush sweetheart
no george was not a swedish he's trained
by prescott
grandfather who was a senator he was
trained by
father cia listen there's training when
you have those kinds of people there's
low key
what i'm trying to tell you is there's
levels to the game the lower level you
are the more peaceful sweet it is the
higher you go
you realize how dirty of a game it is
and if you show any kind of weakness
look flip it if trump doesn't come out
strong
what do you think they're going to do to
him for the rest of his life if trump
comes out and is quiet like a nixon what
do they do for the rest of his life
i mean they're going to come after him
regardless for everything he's done i
mean trump is who he is it's baked in
the cake he ain't changing
here here's my prediction my prediction
that donald trump of 2015 2016 is
officially gone
he has no like his highest approval
ratings ever
would never reach 50 percent he is now
baked in the cake the 30 percent of the
of their country or you know the gop is
fractured we talk about the
the democrats having issues with the
socialists in the left the moderates
it is a clear fracture in the republican
party you're either with trump or
against them if you're just a normal
conservative
you know george will mitt romney george
bush type
republican and there's tens of millions
of people like that
you're on one side of the aisle if
you're a mega trump
you know may you know that whole vibe
you're with trump like you
if trump said i'm starting my own party
which by the way he said he wouldn't do
but if he said i'm starting my own party
they're going with trumpism but he
didn't say i'm starting my own party so
i never do that so
there's a major fracture in the gop and
what we've learned
in 2020 in this election unless you
coalesce and come together
as a party as a unit as a full-on
just cohesive unit you're not winning a
general election
sorry you could play to your base yeah
all you want buddy you ain't winning the
general election so
keep doing that keep you know fracture
fractalizing the
the adam kinzingers and the liz cheney's
of the world and the
lisa murkowskis and the susan collins
keep going after them
clear division in the gop and i don't
think he has any shot
of winning the actual presidency if he
does run again in 2024
but he'll clearly be the nominee if he
wants that he'll clearly be the nominee
clearly be the nominee nobody get his
ass kicked even by a
dementia sleepy joe that's my prediction
what are your thoughts on cpac
on to you though i know he's lost
all momentum from did you bringing the
country together
i thought it was expected so knowing his
personality he
he's very vindictive and he
is very firm in how he thinks things
should be
and in this you're either for him or
you're against him
i know that and and i i think there is
a a huge majority of the republican base
that is exactly what you're talking
about it's it's much more
mainstream if you will and more liberal
in
in certain ways um that i think is going
to be
left out but if he's still
interested in running which i think he
will be in four years i do believe he's
gonna run again
and a lot of people who were upset about
what happened
during the capital insurrection will
have to decide
which way they want to go because there
are so many republicans who voted for
donald trump
not because they love or support what he
stands for
but because they want to vote republican
for lower taxes and
you know different lifestyle right less
regulation
um i think it's gonna run um i think
he's gonna continue to do exactly what
you talked about and you know
you asked me what i love about this
country it's freedom of speech
but he's shown some authoritarian
traits that make it more uncomfortable
for people like liz cheney to say
exactly what she wants to say so that's
the part that i don't like because
i grew up in a socialist country where
you can't speak your mind
i think in this country we all came
seeking freedom of speech so
with him it's going to be much more
difficult
and i think polarized as we go forward
but i do believe he's going to run
i think i agree with you i clearly think
he's the favorite and if you
chose to be the run in 2024
i think what he's going to do is he's
going to
just keep doing what donald does and
just
and wait until the midterms and what
he'll do
is sort of dangle the trump card
for a lack of a better term over anyone
running in the midterms
and if you were with him he will go all
in with you and if you're against him
he will like a bat out of hell come at
you for the liz cheney's of the world
the susan collins of the murkowskis and
um you know anyone who voted against him
he will make
he will do his damnedest to make sure
they are not elected
and um the guy kinzinger actually was on
the news i
apologize i forgot his name adam
kinslicker he said listen in my district
i won 65 percent of the vote and he's a
republican
um donald won 52 so the mats on my side
and that's something
that stop what do you mean oh my gosh
district against nation i mean stop
so that's who this is as a congressman
that's the winner is this is fully get
that i fully
okay this is bigger than what would uh
everything that's okay
so let me ask you this question here
what feeling do you get
when you hear nancy pelosi speaking an
annoying grandma
okay fair enough yeah okay would you
agree with that paul i don't want to
offend paul because i know he's a
diehard
from california yeah so what what
feeling do you get when you hear
hillary clinton speaking smart robot
smart robot like she just repeats she's
just kind of doing you know
what what feeling do you get when barack
obama speaks swaggy
100 percent i
love watching his energy people oh my
gosh you know i
when he when i watch his interview with
leno or
letterman or you just are like man cool
baby
cool right now okay what what do you
what do you think about when you hear
reagan speaking
american icon american icon yeah but you
know you look at them you're like
you know i like this guy comedy fun all
that okay
what feeling do you get when you get joe
biden speaking
um uh dementia slash empathy
really he's a little slow but he cares
okay you can tell he cares
he's got a big heart cool slow brain
that's how you feel when you get a joke
okay
what feeling do you get when you get uh
trump speaking nails on a chalkboard
okay now watch this yeah that's for you
yeah and about sixty percent of the
customers no no but
wait wait where i'm going i'm with you
i'm with you it's
75 million people vote if you
underestimate this guy you're gonna
experience exactly what you experienced
in 2015 2016. okay
so now flip this what do hillary clinton
lovers
feel when they hear hillary clinton
speak are there really actual hillary
clinton lovers 100
just go to connecticut just just go
there and you'd see
she's such a sweetheart you don't
remember when she lost how bad people
were crying when she
wasn't so much that she lost it was that
donald trump became the president
go talk to somebody who loves you know
a a or who hates barack obama when
barack obama speaks what do they say
he's a terrorist he's not even american
but they'll say he's spirit i want to
see his
pompous he's arrogant he's this he's
that right so
but but the part you have to think about
is your mushroom
you cannot because i think this is going
to get to one area this is the one area
it's good it's only one question we have
to ask
it's only one question okay so it's
not about whether you agree with this
guy's policies or not
everything he said was the same thing
except for one thing
except for one thing one of the things
he said he's never talked about before
he said are you noticing what joe
biden's trying to do to women
did you notice the the recent you know
thing he signed where transvestites can
compete now in any kind
what is what's gonna happen in women's
sports why are you gonna play tennis why
are you gonna play basketball why are
you gonna do this so that was a new
thing he threw in by the way it's so
controversial
that's similar to what he did five years
ago when he said what
get him out of here so now
oh my gosh we can't even talk about this
no no he's
brilliant in his marketing and his
strategy so
why would he say something like that
that is a part and a base on the other
side i can say what you know
he's right okay he's right and that's
the democrats always been what
protecting all you know we're partying
for the women so that's kind of going to
backfire there because
you know he knows how to play the the
divisive game just as good as these guys
knows how to play the device well first
of all there's no doubt just so you know
his enemies are dirtier than he is just
so you know his opponents are 10
times dirtier than he is but they're
private he's public
anytime a person publicly shares their
strategies
it doesn't mean they're the dirtier one
the private one is the one that doesn't
say anything but behind closed doors is
like let me see how bad i'm going to
make your life a living kale
so he's not the dirtiest you agree with
his public strategy of airing the
grievances
i agree you just heard a woman that
worked with her for a
high-ranking vp work with him for six
years explained to you how he
is nothing has changed for this guy to
run the way he runs things
i mean i can already see how he runs the
sales meetings i can already visualize
how he would drive a sales people
this this the point i'm trying to get to
you the only question we have to answer
is the following
the only question we have to answer is
the following can he win
without twitter facebook and youtube
that's it
yeah if he can he's gonna win
if he cannot he ain't gonna win it's
that simple by the way is he
permanently banned he's permanently
banned from twitter okay
youtube he's safe but when you do a
youtube interview with him
and if he even comments on saying
you know you guys know this was a rigged
election you guys won the election
fraud youtube youtube disclaimer to take
that video down because
put together uh not just that they're
able to take the video
down all the way well youtube said
anybody that talks about election fraud
they're taking those videos down
youtube made that announcement so he
can't go and say
you know well let me tell you something
you know they really stole this from us
et cetera et cetera how much hour 75
million
so the question we all have to answer is
not even a political question i don't
care how you feel about his uh
you know the wall 500 miles the only
question we all have to answer is can
this guy win
without twitter social media so if
you're watching this i'm curious if
you're watching this
right now we have 441 thumbs up
we have five thumbs down okay so 441
to five five thumbs down press thumbs up
if you think he can win without twitter
facebook
and youtube press thumbs down if you
don't think he can win without twitter
facebook youtube i'm curious to know
what people are gonna say but what do
you think
you hit the nail on the head i got i got
to give you kudos for for
for injecting the actual logical
non-emotional
question here at hand because that's
exactly
the scenario that we should be asking is
can he win without
having big tech you know by his side or
at least
allowing him to vocalize his thoughts
without twitter
there is no donald trump presidency you
know who
who was it that you interviewed the
other day oliver north he said i wish
that
trump would put down the damn phone
something to that effect
without twitter um he's gonna end
without
you know a certain certain other extent
i don't know if facebook
instagram youtube if they're all banning
him from the platform
um he has two options that he's going to
either need to go with the mainstream
media
which clearly they're not a fan or he'll
need to speak into
the echo chamber that is newsmax
parlor oan and he's just going to be
playing to his base and one thing we've
known about
the sales game or politics is you need
to be able to what
convert and if you're just playing to
your 30
or 40 percent good luck out there hoss
you need to get to at least 51
so i to answer your question
specifically
what's what's your point no chance
without big tech eyesight
okay do you guys agree no chance he wins
without big tech
paul do you agree without big tech
yeah he he needs to convert people okay
eric can he win without twitter facebook
youtube
definitely not and i think even with it
it's gonna be hard for him okay so
that's a good so that's interesting and
that's a trump guy right there yeah and
that's a marine guy saying what he said
okay
kai can he win without twitter facebook
youtube
i think it'd be challenging especially
considering like his track record he's
not an unknown there's a lot of people
that
were initially thought hey let's give
him
let's give him the benefit of the doubt
um in the first time around but now
without that and also without tech i see
it as a very
hard for him to sonata what do you come
out and win i'm with the marine
with or without it's with or without
because he just lost
the support of so many mainstream
republicans so many women
that this um hardcore
you know rhetoric i don't think is going
to get him far because
i feel talking to so many clients and
friends
you know as republicans a lot of them
don't want to be associated with
with proud boys with such extremist
groups
and that's sort of the main um support
group now for trump
yeah so here's here's where i'm going
with this if
if you look at the republican party like
a sports team right now
and they have to draft somebody right
because that's what you're looking at
right now you're
initial essentially you're looking for a
top draft pick to build your team around
and you've got to have one person like
you're looking for lebron james you're
looking for a person to build a team
around
not a talent like you can't build around
carmelo and win a championship
you can't build around certain people
but you can build around lebron you can
build around kobe you can build around
certain players right
[Music]
if i'm in that room and it's the 20 big
decision makers of the rnc republican
party
if you don't have a solution for twitter
facebook youtube
you better start putting it on somebody
else and by the way that's that includes
cpac
that includes a lot if you don't have
another platform where this guy can code
because we're so imagine he wants to say
something who does he call
like you know when you want to make an
announcement what do you say hey i'm
doing a
you know get all the media out here okay
cool
everybody's in front of you 40 cameras
so here's what we're going to do i
noticed earlier today what happened in
new york i think it's a travesty with
cuomo the governor it's time to imp
okay you need that where is he going
who's it going to call aon
is he going to call news who's he going
to call that's true
there's no right who's he going to no
you can't even call fox fox is not even
going that direction fox is also kind of
going more center right
fox is now going far right i mean
tucker's staying there hannity's staying
there but not everybody's staying there
right so the opinion people will but not
the news people in fox but but it's not
an
audience to convert he converted people
on twitter facebook youtube
so if the rnc gets
emotionally closed behind closed doors
by trump but they don't have a solution
for another platform for him to speak
you just have to be thinking about it so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye